In the previous examples, we were looking at our
data Age and Friend Count across the categorical variable Gender.
Usually, color or shape tend to be aesthetics for
representing such changes over a categorical variable. But what if
we looked at Age and Friend Count over, say,
another numerical variable? For example we might notice that since
users are likely to accumulate friends over time using Facebook
that Facebook tenure is important for predicting friend count. Tenure
or how many days since registering with Facebook is associated
with age. The first people to start using Facebook were college
students as of 2004 and 2005. I was lucky enough to
be part of that group and joined the site on February
3rd, 2005. As a result, I've amassed more friends over time
and have over 1,200 of them. On the other hand, 14
year-old users, have had less time to accumulate the same number
of friends. One way to explore all four variables friend count,
age, gender and tenure is using a two-dimensional display
like a scatter plot. And we can bend one of
the quantitative variables and compare those bends. In this
case, we can group users by the year that they
joined. So let's create a new variable called year_joined
in our data frame. This variable is going to hold the
year that our users first joined Facebook. In our next
program and exercise, you're going to create this variable, year_joined,
and put it inside the data frame. You need to make
use of the variable tenure and use 2014 as the reference year.